the five most amazing opening ideas
of the legend gary kasparov gary
was famous for some of his opening
innovations
and we're gonna look at his five most
famous here
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel otherwise i'll be on your case
i'll find you i'll track you down first
example like
most of these examples is taken from a
world
championship match the most important
kind of match in the world the world
championship match
yes it is and it's against karpov with
the black pieces played in moscow
in 1985 and this was a key
win for kasparov who started with the
sicilian
and they went into the so-called tamanov
where we have this normal structure here
knight b5 still one of the main lines we
don't let that knight in
so d6 and now c4 the so-called moroxy
bind situation black
develops and after knight to c3
a6 knight to a3 karpov must be feeling
very happy with himself here because
he's got
a little bind on the center of the board
and he's controlling gripping
the position up to this point in time
everyone had gone bishop e7
and black's a little bit worse but gary
now comes up with
d5 oh i have some of that cup off
and this move just breaks open the
position
at the cost of a whole pawn but look at
black's pieces they just
fly into the game this gave gary a very
important win
maybe one of the most important wins on
his way to becoming world champion
in 1985. karpov now took
a couple of times on this square and you
might be thinking where's black's
compensation white has this
tremendous extra pawn what is
compensation
lies in this night here this knight is a
beautiful piece
it can't be kicked away because white
has a knight on that square
and after both sides develop very
normally
you can see black brings all his pieces
into play
takes the open file pushes on the queen
side
and eventually sticks that knight on
d3 and this knight is certainly worth a
pawn
it controls e1 is in the middle of the
board there was a fret of b4 here
and gary went on to win with his vast
piece
of superiority here so a lovely idea
that d5 and
really a slap in the fish slapping the
fish
well cardboard was actually called a
fish by coachnoy but i meant to say face
with a fish by casper aroff let's just
move on to the next one shall we
the next one the world championship
match between karpov and kasparov again
in 1990 new york now i'm gonna go
through the opening moves with these
things very quickly
so you can see where the novelties came
from and this one was a king's
indian defense one of gary's best
openings
best weapons and they got to a position
that
has been seen many times before on about
move 13 where
black has just broken with d5 but white
keeps the position closed down and up to
this point most players have just played
bishop d7
and white's considered to be a little
bit better because of the pressure there
but gary plays a phenomenal idea
he plays rook takes e3 i remember the
first time i saw it so i was like what
is this
amazing concept because there's no
immediate follow-up
after queen takes e3 for example knight
g4
doesn't even work that well because the
knight takes c6 and the queen is
attacked
but the idea is just queen f8
there is now a threat of knight g4 and
black's going for
dark square compensation he's trying to
prove that his bishop
is actually stronger than a rook because
white has weakened his dark squares with
some idea
like f3 and i think for a beginner like
i was when i first saw this it was a
very
hard idea to get to grips with but
look at how black's pieces just have
great activity i'm going to whiz through
the moves
this bishop beautiful this rook gains
a very useful line there the rook now
comes in
and now the last piece is developed and
black is very solid in the center as
well
knight b2 the knight now opens
up so the bishop gets active that knight
may even be able to attack on the dark
squares
white forces the rook over here but gary
now threatens
knight g3 the queen gets its way around
and now bishop d4 diverting the queen
away from the king's side to force okay
only a draw but let's remember a draw
with black in the world championships is
a great result
and the whole concept i just found
simply astonishing there
giving up the rook for the dark squares
for long-term play
positional compensation well i'm going
for lots of lessons in the kingdom
defense and this one
karpov kasparov again i'm going to whiz
through the
moves it happens on move 19. in a
position that's been seen many times
before this was in tilburg not the world
championships
and they played the mainline kings
indian where white attacks on the queen
side black on the king side
and they get to a position which is
considered up to the point in time
by firing 2b a little bit better for
white
because you can see white's progress on
the queen side is coming
very quickly white gaining a load of
space but here we see
a simply astonishing idea
now previously up to this point black
had tried stuff like f4 but after g4
things are closed down and not really
well you're losing a piece there
and other ideas well where is the
compensation well gary now comes up with
an idea which just again must have
taken carp off by surprise knight takes
g3 poor old karpov
so often just taken by surprise
and this is an astonishing idea let's
remember these opening novelties were
often found when computers weren't
strong so they're found before the
tournament by a team of helpers
the idea of this is to bring the other
knight in and to target
g3 now after f4 the game
got very complex and eventually ended in
a draw
but let me just show you one of the main
concepts behind this
which is if king g2 well now we can do
the double
sacrifice knight takes g3
and after king takes f4 check it might
look like it's only going to be a draw
with some perpetual but black
is winning eventually the black queen
will force the king into h1 and as soon
as we get this situation we don't have
to repeat
we can try to get the rook in the game
with g5
and funnily enough there's no way white
can stop this maneuver
so white is lost the king's in defense
in gary's hands was just a spectacular
weapon
study his games if you want to learn
about this opening
yet another king's indian defense this
time against kramnik in 1994.
it was only a blitz game but gary was
able to unleash
yet another astonishing peace queen
sacrifice this time now they follow the
mainline king's indian and again we're
going to get to
the main position after normal moves and
the main position
does occur on move 12 in a position that
has been seen
before up to this point g5 queen e8 have
been tried
but now kasparov plays one of the most
astonishing ideas
of the time and still nowadays
knight on f takes e4
he leaves his queen on pre and he only
gets two pieces and a pawn for it
after the fourth sequence bishop takes
queen knight takes c3
the queen has to guard the bishop and
now rook takes d8
but what has black got in compensation
but he's got this
fantastic bishop which will come to life
after e4
he's also got tremendous activity
with the two knights here these knights
are very tricky but maybe most
importantly
white doesn't have any harmony with his
pieces
so black can just simply improve
his situation by pushing forwards of
course kramnik probably thought he was
winning here
judging by any of his interviews but
things quickly went wrong
after knight takes a2 and knight b4 the
knights
jumping in the e4 pawn comes up the
board
and white has not really managed to do
anything but black's been slowly
improving
f5 f4 e3 ideas like this
all coming together and the position is
just horrible for white
brilliant brilliant play and a brilliant
idea yet again from gary
well to finish with we're actually
having an idea that gary had with the
white pieces
and this was played against vichy van
anad
in the world championship match pca
world championships
in 1995. this started off again
with an opening that's been seen many
times before the open
rule lopez and the open rule lopez is
after knight takes e4 black decides to
grab this one
d4 now they follow established theory
all the way
up to move 14 and on move 14
which we're gonna see here with queen d3
white had previously gone knight f3
because
of course it seems that there's lots of
things dropping and after the queen's
come off
it's considered to be okay for black but
gary came up with
some brilliant preparation it wasn't
just one move it was a little
series of moves that he must have had
prepared in depth
before arriving at the board and it
starts with
bishop c2 this novelty now on its own
this doesn't seem like much but after
queen takes c3
knight b3 we see the real point behind
it
gary's also going to give up his rook
but he's keeping
anan's king stuck in the center it can't
castle
and we have a queen coming out to h5
and ant now took on b3 and only here
maybe did he see
taking the queen would be very risky for
example if he grabs it here
we come in with check and you can well i
think it's easy to see
just how dangerous things will become
with these ones coming
g6 queen of freeze a great move and all
the light squares in black's position
drop
the game continued in quite similar
fashion with knight d4
queen g4 queen takes a1
but after some more moves bishop h6
this is just simply crushing for
white the queen is on pre and we're
trying to get rid of the g
pawn for the white queen to come in i
think i've even looked at this position
this move bishop h6 and gary kasparov's
most amazing moves of all time
but this is still probably his
preparation and if that bishop is taken
we can even just come to f7 because
there's no g6 to
to block that so again astonishing
concepts by gary there brilliant play
and he really was a master of opening
preparation
please like this video and do subscribe
to the channel it does
help me make more if you want to see
more
and again i think these ideas really
shaped modern day chess somebody's
aggressive intentions that
gary came up with and maybe you guys at
home can even
come up with a little opening idea
yourselves with this
inspiration